vous posez des questions a tous je
revienne répond également et vous allez
me répondre parce que c'est des choses
qui se passent dans la pièce est ce que
comme dans la pièce y en a déjà eu tu as
envie de se barrer en vaut vivre en
suisse vous avez déjà vu en vidéo parle
ensuite n'ont jamais non jamais vous
barrez hors de france n'ont jamais ouais
vous êtes un homme bien j'aime bien
paris j'aime bien la france cela vous
permet à montier louis non banon d'abord
j'ai pas les moyens et en plus tous les
amis qui sont allés ils sont tous
revenus des raisons fiscales ils sont
tous revenus
vous matthieu delormeau alors moi
j'avais bien partir mais pas celui ci
paraît que c'est très fins et pour toi
voilà
six mois je pourrais j'adore les
ouailles à beaucoup de bruit aux abords
les matchs en live adore les chalets
mosaïque chemise kaboul
avait perdu chocolat elle a tari chez
1400 ou non mais vous quand j'arrive au
genou vivre à monaco moi à oui dès ce
week-end
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
l'été je suis fou de monaco pris mon
groupe habitera ensemble avec plaisir à
moi j'adore
je sais pas la tension s'est pas à
monaco il ya un truc ya un truc qui se
paye
ton clause n ya pas d oeil à monaco
les postiers sont en ferrari jaune
[Rires]
les idées reçues vous aimez pas les
bouchons mais ça circule encore moins
bien qu'à paris c'est combien que
manquer c'est en fait c'est la banque et
séduction à moi j'aime marcher 1 monaco
je suis sur le rocher je marche on n'a
rien on ira bitam on a concédé très beau
jacuzzi à monaco bon ben c'est bon
gars mais vous embête tout le monde
est ce que comme dans la pièce il vous
est arrivé d'inviter des amis en vous
disant mais pourquoi je leur ai dit de
venir oui
j'invite pendant 90 1 j'invite pas fait
très peur nadal lui n'avait pas
c'est vrai que non non josiane je vous
jure de toute ma vie je n'ai jamais
invité des amis à dîner à la maison ah
non vous croisez parce que vous êtes
sûrs que disait pas faire appel
a
plaidé à ce que vous êtes incapable de
rester à table pendant plus de dix
minutes va donc mettre à danser
le monsieur qui part ou non mais c'est
vrai donc non non j'ai invité non non
j'invite des copains je fais gaffe parce
que j'ai pas une excellente cuisinière
dont je leur dis qu'ils seront pas
malade ouais quand même et l'essentiel
mais bon c'est pas voilà white house
diary des gilles verdez alors moi je
n'arrive plus jamais personne à la
maison mais parce que personne ne vient
c'est exactement
[Applaudissements]
la corse
à se faire inviter oui mais pas du tout
je m'intéresse beaucoup jeudi à la
question vous avez posé josé david paris
je sais mais le quartier très
sympathique est-ce que vous avez une
petite flamme dit mieux encore quelques
secrets une résidence secondaire
quelques mois oui oui dans le sud dans
le midi way a donc me dis
que je vais savoir je veux mieux
connaître josiane à ce qui est plutôt à
la campagne dans le midi ou de balades
vous êtes bancaire les week-ends de la
pièce oui pas cause la pièce pistons
genou je me que j'aime bien paris moi je
sais dans le sud
sans faute d'accord il dit c'est vrai je
vous j'adore faire des dix ans vous avez
invité françois hollande et moi j'adore
jouer au marché je prépare des menus en
visite dans l'assemblée générale d'hier
à ses formidables ouais ouais zoellick
reçu géraldine meira voyage à paris
aussi personnes moins vite
personne nulle part aux invités on
attendait plus tard la tester ouais
c'est vrai meneur chez moi ouais j'avais
dépassé quoi vous en fait c'était plus
régulièrement et cela s'est vu
régulièrement on était à deux maisons
l'un de l'autre pas forcément moyennant
quoi on a fait un gros séminaire de
travail ouais c'est vrai et vous m'avez
invité chez oui je suis abattu après la
prochaine pour plaisir si je vous invite
à dîner vous venez oui arrêtez de cette
année là
voilà peut-être prochainement mes
invités - franchement avec les médias
auraient l'idée avec vous et fatou j'ai
le faire avec plaisir sa pétition il est
déjà assez bon avec ça tout va quoi
manger halal est
en tout cas les invités moi je viendrai
avec grand plaisir à lire je voudrais
prochainement dîner je vous inviterai
josiane est
ce que ça donne dans la pièce j'avais
déjà eu des problèmes avec le fisc
dommage qu'ils aient pas benjamin
castaldi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais non alors si je sais que
quand j'étais plus jeune
il y avait eu une toute unité il ya des
courants des courants du rumeur qui se
répand et qu'ils doivent se répandre
aussi au ministère des impôts impôts et
tout ça comme quoi les acteurs faisait
du black c'est très difficile pour un
homme en fin de compte on m'avait fait
une vaste vérification approfondie de la
votre situation fiscale ce personnage
que j'avais joué d'ailleurs d'anciennes
extérieurs de richesse et donc je suis
allé avec tout mais chez qui est nommé
truqués mon mari et moi et on les a mis
dans des sacs poubelle savait pas et on
est arrivé là bas et
gentiment a compris vraiment il rien et
surtout il avait vu cette fois le film
de cette fois se détériore nos richesses
donc et ses démons et donc ça s'est mal
terminée ça a pris du temps parce qu'il
faut mais on n'a pas eu droit à ce
moment ni rien mais bon ces personnes
ici moi si ah oui mais non ça vient ça
vient de me revenir soir
les anecdotes pour soir alors madame
vous êtes en salle de réveil
vous êtes en salle de réveil l'opération
génère
vraiment tout s'est très bien passé
votre mari va venir vous recherchez leur
donnant un sens je raconte règne pour
josiane qui s'en fout alors c'est quoi
alors la bd quand j'étais à vsd il
m'avait oublié une grosse somme sur
meriem d'oublier de me verser une somme
d'argent chaque mois et comme je regarde
jamais une fiche de paye je m'en étais
pas rendu compte et quand vsd a été
liquidée il on est obligé de me
rétrocéder une très grosse somme
d'argent mais moi je savais pas qu'il
fallait déclarer je n'ai pas déclaré et
donc bien ils m'ont convoqué j'ai dit
alain mon mari tu viens avec moi parce
que je comprends rien ce qui me va me
raconter
mon mari fait très attention au compte
de votre femme parce qu'elle est très
con d'accord ça s'est confirmé ensuite
bas bravo il n'était pas complètement in
intéressés c'est ce
que vit aussi tu sens pas tant parce que
comme dans la pièce vous avez déjà
réussi à respirer par la nuit moi j'ai
essayé parce que dans la pièce
c'est le gourou le gourou les faire
respirer par une séance comme ça dans la
passion real est alors j'avais juste
idée parce que c'était parti tournée aux
antilles en venant dans l'avion j'étais
à côté d'une des jeunes actrices qui
était aussi plongeuse et incidemment on
parle de plongée sous-marine et elle me
dit les tortues de mer respire par
l'anus et comme j'étais en train
d'écrire la pièce
c'est tout à fait le genre de
respiration qu'un gourou inspiré
pourrait demander à voir proposer à ses
clients
dont j'ai pas des tortues dans une autre
vie dont nous venons ce palace un
serpent si je veux toucher devant quand
vous me regardez pas je regarde benhaim
jeu super bass
j'ai attaqué le malheur de vote double
valérie bénaïm elle respire par le cul
mais plus
rien à voir si on regarde par la vive
est devenu maire en parlant de respirer
par les fesses il faut savoir que c'est
très dangereux de souffler dans un vagin
oh non
[Rires]
je les lui il n'y a pas longtemps
mais dans quel me résigne tulle
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
des
routes niveau des intestins des poumons
déjà aux maîtresses avait juste fait ça
pourquoi il ya des trompes étaient
américains non mais croit qu'il ya
vraiment
bien naïve sert il à quoi vous êtes bien
naïf à
limbé saïda à jouir
[Applaudissements]
mais aucun de toi
il est [ __ ]
c'est vrai c'est horrible excuser les
jeudis à t'excuser d est ce que comme
dans la pièce vous avez déjà eu des
amants
céder avant c'est-à-dire des amants
c'est à dire sans que le mari de sa wii
non non aux abandons jamais jamais j'ai
eu des amants avons assez vous n'avez
jamais trompé josiane non je suis
quelqu'un de fidèle 20 ans et 20 ans
lâchent et avec bon c'est le cinéma
revoilà voilà donc tu sais vraiment non
bien aux gens tombent même passion
ça va oui très bien alors oui ça m'est
déjà arrivé de quoi les amendes et
fidèle dans l'ue se dit déjà
à huy voilà j'en suis pas fier à
d'accord mais il a un qui me parle non
non
il ya eu un
effet non y avait un effet drôle gens
qui me parlent comme a fait une
excellente émission une excellente
saison certainement la dernière
nicolas pernikoff c'est toujours dans
l'émission
écoute ou alors alors quoi alex toi
jamais ça m'est jamais arrivé vite
possible
non je suis fidèle mais perdit pas
raconter j'ai toujours été fidèle mais
un mathieu s'il comprend pas qu'on se
fout de la gueule et téléspectateurs
[Applaudissements]
alors marc était jeune j'étais très
volage jeunes aura un peu un homme dans
chaque port ah oui non pas au sérieux
moi
j'étais sur la bonne voie mais c'est
vrai et puis après
je me suis assagi j'ai trouvé l'amour et
je suis très fidèle depuis ma mémoire ça
c'était quaïda où j'étais très jeune oui
j'irai les 20 ans 21 ans 20 de saison et
ça je voyage et j'avais un peu des
hommes partout [ __ ] c'est bravo pas
franchement voilà alors puisque vous me
demandez
intéressant pour joseph quand j'étais
plus jeune j'avais vu un psy parce que
je n'arrivais pas à se dissocier l'amour
le sexe c'est à dire que si j'avais
envie de coucher à quelqu'un je ne
pouvais pas être amoureux et si j'étais
amoureux je n'ai insulté personne qu'on
produit
[Applaudissements]
des inconnus
c'est à dire de moi c'est un truc de
gens connus beauté oui c'est un trader
c'était plus jeune ça m'est arrivé ça ah
oui et maintenant vous voulez en parler
non maintenant j'arrive heureusement
soucier si hocine catastrophe by naim
cette fidèle sinon je qui j'ai pris fin
ce dimanche vous ne devriez pas
non mais moi si moi si je sens que ça va
plus en fait je me barre l accord
bino v10 séjour fidèles malheureusement
toujours fidèle toujours a
malheureusement alors là des fois c'est
pas mérité non c'est pas vrai bah ouais
c'est la vie bah écoutez ballet falls et
les foules mais ce qui dérange été
débordé par le succès
des conneries là c'est quand je suis
déliter deuxième super nes super nes est
très fidèle
vous étiez débordé pour ma dans l'est en
fait j'allais à la sortie des défilés de
mannequins j'avais beaucoup de jeter les
mégots de râteau mais j'avais aussi
beaucoup de succès et je savais quand la
police vous amène au commissariat succès
avec ça ça a été une période compliquée
ouais d'accord ouais ouais ouais pas
très bien oui mais sérieux oui vous avez
vous fait je suis étonné que je suis
irréprochable
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je vais vous dire je suis tellement
droit dans mes bottes a franchement
c'est un basket
tu sors
[Applaudissements]
je suis fidèle et vous le savez un
fidèle dans le travail l'amour fidèle en
amitié fidèle en argent surtout
c'est vrai c'est important le lit
qu'est-ce qui a oui oui bernard et les
sorties monsieur la sortie
[Applaudissements]
deux accords
mais oui elle est sortie le mal
[Rires]
être
est ce que comme dans la pièce j'avais
déjà pensé à devenir vegan
de temps en temps à mes yeux de temps en
temps mais juste pour un entrée par
exemple c'est tout forme une entrée au
delà c'est non oui mais non est ici on
accueille non moi savons tu vegan depuis
quatre jours c'est un vrai succès
c'est à dire depuis quatre jours ouais
c'est un succès acquis
vous m'inquiéter de la
défense près qu'on va faire complètement
incohérent
mais vraiment toutes les banques à faire
un avc
au
départ j'ai fait ça pour des sous les
premiers gestes de secours
[Rires]
vérifier nos débats oui oui j'ai compris
nuit et vous avez compris que nous ne
pêchons roturier jamais vieille fille
encore maintenant vous avez fait non pas
encore non je pense que c'est normal
proche ah oui mais arrêtez vous
accrochez vous accrocher à beaucoup de
monde et donc la voie je continue ah
ouais ouais ouais c'est un truc qu'on
peut manger de la nourriture asiatique
rien à voir avec des gammes les japonais
il ya des yade et bien sûr que
là mais je dirais les sushis
est revenu qui vous ai dit de venir tout
le monde si la ferveur publics gares
déjà pensé à devenir vegan ah non non
parce que j'ai à vous dire puisque vous
me demandez genève
je vous jure j'ai l'impression d'être à
une réunion des alcooliques anonymes
[Applaudissements]
beyrouth ap des missions qui les
quartiers 15 minutes
le monsieur la sortie de wii alors oui
alors je n'ai je pas ramener tout à ça
mais je n'ai jamais rencontré un vegan
ou un végétarien qui fasse bien l'amour
mais vous de penser qu'à ça donc je
pense qu'il ya une sorte de plaisir de
la nourriture qui va les ir tout coup
allez petit sujet avancent que les gens
vegan végétalien sont chiants et dont la
finition je pense que des films peut
être qu'on peut très beau être hayat
rameau etc ou alors va t on demandera
des films de malfrats dans l'édition
je ne sais pas mon mari mange de la
viande
oui j'ai bien documenté la sucette
stimule les performances sexuelles et
khoualed reagan ont fait des expériences
avec des mecs qui mangent de la viande
et des mecs qui étaient les nôtres tout
ne pas te retrouver avec un haricot dans
le cycle
des gaffes fait c'est totalement faux
mathieu ce sont des gens les vegan qui
prennent soin de l'environnement effet
un pardon des dégâts non mais j'y
réfléchis parfois je mangerai peu moins
rien non rien et du coup c'est vrai
c'est des gens qui du coup prennent soin
de l'environnement et prennent soin de
l'autre pas tous bien sûr qui s'occupe
de l'autre d'accord probablement jour 1a
du jour outre
est ce que comme dans la pièce vous
aimez les toilettes qui ont des chasses
d'eau qui vous nettoie les fesses tout
seul hors jeu les toilettes japonaises
parce que c'est ce qu'a dans la pièce
oui enfin c'est ce dont on parle c'est
jean marie mon mari construisent un peu
ses manigances ce genre de et il a mis
au point une nouvelle d'ailleurs qu'ils
sont en train de mettre au point une
nouvelle toilette qui fait coloscopie en
même temps
c'est un gros marché est convaincu de la
série qui est installé vous êtes
extrêmement riche pas où ils s'appellent
ça c'est kutscher s'appelle totaux ça
coûte quoi 2000 euros le toilettes 3008
l avez-vous les fesses tout seul juste à
les voires extrêmement léger nique hier
ce qui est marrant c'est que sur la
petite ya une petite télécommande comme
marc attend si vous pouvez pardon c'est
pas du tout ça se jouera contre mais
c'est vrai vous pouvez soit nettoyé le
lan us soit si c'est une femme la marque
et donc le plus tôt la parcelle de la
femme vous choisissez avec le sexe
un
bouton qui certes mais mais mais oui
j'ai très contente s'attache à
3800 euros ici est ce qu'il ya un truc
pour sécher après oui alors il ya un
tube pourrait lâcher ya la cuvette qui
chauffe en chauffante absolument oui oui
elle automatiquement me paraît
absolument aspirations donc pendant que
respiration de donc acheté 0 nord
marine-4 qui vous aspire pas tout
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai des amis crise qui bon parfois aux
toilettes et je vois bien qu'au bout de
dix minutes soit parvenu c'est un lieu
de vie
c'est l'animation et ouais vous n'êtes
pas chez vous c'est pas un nom mais ça
tire la chasse tout seul d'ailleurs j'ai
eu un premier extrait pourquoi en fait
moi c'est mon histoire mais en fait j'ai
un problème c'est que je ne peux pas
quand je suis en couple je ne peux pas
aller aux toilettes dans la même pièce
ou même endroit que la personne bien sûr
j'étais avec une amie dans un hôtel
c'est rare aussi que
j'étais avec une amie dans un hôtel et
elle me dit
j'étais avec une amie dans un hôtel que
vous connaissez d'ailleurs ans quand
même le dit l'hôtel où l'ami oui les
deux et au lalano dit je vais faire des
courses pendant deux heures assis quand
même je dirais et dont je vous dis moi
je vais enfin pour aller aux toilettes
je vais aux toilettes je descendrai
celle de sport de l'hôtel je vais courir
et au bout de 45 minutes jean poutge pas
tirer la chasse non au et je remonte
mais en transpirant je la vois elle
ouvre la porte j'étais en panique et
j'ai ouvert la porte et la chasse été
tirés mais je n'ai jamais su si j'avais
tiré la chasse ou pas
nadia tic le talent des asiatiques que
ces deux marques asiatiques ces
toilettes l'accolade
avant ce qu'ils ont écrit sur la
connerie des français
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vous qui êtes obsédé par la propreté et
révisionniste est ce que ça vous tente
ce genre de chiottes alors je l'avais
déjà l'avait bien je je je je je vous
aimez vous avez un j'en ai un à mai à la
rue moi j'en joue le moins j'ai lu j'ai
eu à moitié prix l'audi pas parce que je
connaissais le fabricant ni toi moitié
alors votre verdict quoi c'est
exceptionnel a franchement avant c'est
quand on le paye pas cher c'est encore
vous
devriez essayer jugez vous aimez de ges
je dis pas je demande au nom c'est moi
qui posais la question devenait fou a
pas du tout oui ah oui non j'avais une
petite info encore bien sûr ce sont pas
figées le temps que
[Rires]
cette pratique peut être dangereuse
parce que ça augmente la prolifération
des microbes parce que les gens
généralement ne prennent pas le temps de
sécher leur anus et donc du coup je
vomis cause ça me va pas du tout donc si
vous allez faire attention à ces chez
vous bien elle a raison qu'ils émigrent
en famille grâce à michel cymes du cul
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]